The massive cargo ship that's been blocking the Suez Canal since last week...
...has finally been freed,...
...and the huge backlog of other vessels,...
...hundreds of them waiting to pass through, is starting to move again.
That's according to the Canal Authority on Monday.
The 430-yard behemoth known as the Ever Given, became stuck diagonally...
...across a southern section of the canal in high winds on the 23rd of March...
...when it ran aground, blocking a trade route...
...that is used by about 15 percent of the world's shipping traffic for 6 days...
...and costing the canal 14 to 15 million dollars a day.
The Suez Canal Authority's chairman Admiral Osama Rabi...
...has said that investigations will show that the organization...
...wasn't responsible for the incident.
After dredging an excavation work over the weekend,...
...rescue workers from the authority and a team from Dutch firm Smit Salvage,...
...succeeded in partially refloating the ship earlier on Monday using tugboats...
...according to marine and shipping sources.
The Ever Given is now being moved to a lake that sits along the canal for inspection.
Admiral Rabi has also said it could take from two and a half to three days...
...to clear the traffic jam of other ships.
Shipping group Maersk said the knock-on effects on global shipping...
...could take weeks or months to unravel.